más salarios menos desempleo pensiones
seguras son algunos de los reclamos de
miles de personas en francia la
convocatoria fue liderada por sindicatos
desempleados y estudiantes en una
exigencia de respuestas urgentes
salarial solís y en cuestión de salarios
en cuestión de empleos llevamos meses y
meses haciendo propuestas al gobierno y
de momento lo que vemos es que todos los
que fueron aplaudidos durante la crisis
todavía no han visto revalorizado sus
salarios sale al juego y se lo denuncian
los sindicatos pero también los
manifestantes un equipo de france 24
estuvo presente en parís y habló con
cristal carbón una técnica de
laboratorio que considera insuficiente
el bono de 183 euros a los trabajadores
de la salud recibido en el contexto de
la pandemia los 183 euros son buenas
noticias claro pero hemos visto la
congelación generalizada de salarios por
años y este bono no será ni remotamente
suficiente para mitigar los efectos del
crecimiento del coste de vida
francia está inmerso como toda europa en
un problema con el alza de los precios
de la energía que afecta al bolsillo del
ciudadano este martes el primer ministro
jan castex prometió actuar si los
precios no bajan para primavera de 2022
un escudo tarifario que bloquea el
precio del gas y la electricidad hasta
abril a pote y para proteger no sólo el
poder adquisitivo de los más modestos
sino a todos los consumidores de estas
energías
francia celebra comicios presidenciales
en seis meses por lo que la oposición ha
considerado estas promesas de
electoralistas mientras desde el
gobierno de manuel macrón tratan de que
las protestas de este martes no se
conviertan en una nueva versión de los
chalecos amarillos de 2018